- Oh, s--t.
- Oh, who voted for this?
- All right, cheers.
- Let's get it.
- It is Week 5 punishment time,
and this week, there were three losers.
So FlemLo, Lou and myself
were those losers.
- The only people that
really showed up for me was Derrick Henry
and the Cowboys defense.
- I picked my whole Bengals
receiving corps and Joe Burrow.
- That was your problem.
- Joe went off. Ja'Marr went off.
But Tyler Boyd and Tee,
they let me down this week.
- So for our punishment,
we have to eat the entire banana
with the peel.
- I Googled it.
They said that eating the banana
peel is really healthy.
The antibiotic, the fiber.
- This is the most nutrient-dense
part of the banana.
the fiber.
- This is the most nutrient-dense
part of the banana.
It's also the worst-tasting, so,
here we go.
Oh, my God.
- It tastes like rubber.
- I don't like that s--t.
- This is trash. This is awful.
- Ugh. I'm halfway done.
How you guys doin'?
You holdin' in there?
- Aw, man. Look.
- I feel like I'm eatin' dirt.
- Goodness gracious.
- I don't know
if I'm ever gonna eat a banana again.
Did you guys eat the stem too?
- Oh, s--t.
- I think Lou started with the stem.
- People voted for this. They're sick.
- You almost there, Flem.
- Bro, this the worst part. Bro, I swear.
- Just keep grindin'.
- Last bite.
- We're done.
That was terrible.
We'll see you guys Wednesday.
Interested to see what
the next punishment's gonna be
because it's not gonna be me.
- I'mma come out there like Tyson Fury.
- Don't get used to seeing me here.